[Music]
pyaare therapy news virtual-reality
submitted by Frosted Flakes haw I got a
Cosmo sighs at home love that [ __ ]
virtual reality therapy has become
increasingly common for treating people
with phobias
I would love this do you think if you
put on virtual reality glasses you can
go hiking in your virtual reality world
yes and you can stay air-conditioned
there's nothing better
oh you mean like actual hiking no I mean
like if you're afraid of heights cuz he
afraid it's different right so it's like
it's actually it's not different so I
watched the film with Joseph Joseph
gordon-levitt and it was where he was
dropping that [ __ ] I couldn't watch it
well they called vertigo no I couldn't
watch that a walk because it started
making me feel dizzy because I watched
on IMAX that [ __ ] freak me the [ __ ] out
so is that what it is
is that they're actually exploiting
their phobias in the virtual reality
exploit like oh I'm scared of spiders I
would have liked spiders everywhere
exactly let me show you a video that is
not gonna fix me you're scared of
spiders
this was from 20 years ago like that's
why I'm like that's a stupid ass spider
on a [ __ ] Nintendo spider researching
the last 20 years
yeah it's like a Nintendo 64 graphics
that's just like SimCity 2000 across a
countertop an early experiment in using
virtual canal waters of therapy for
people with a common phobia with VR
patients learn to feel safe on a virtual
high-rise balcony without leaving their
therapists office it's like the Finns
thought they might have been simply
impossible three months ago
been piggybacking on this technology
that was initially developed for video
gaming huh they're saying now that
there's a lot of people that within just
two hours of VR therapy they can like go
ready there's like a lot of improvement
in there
it is in 10 years if VR becomes so good
like like the cinematics like in what's
it called like black ops right so if
like virtual reality is just as good as
that I'll go back to games yeah but what
if it's so real that your brain things
you die
it'll never get that done the black
mirror episode yeah I just want games to
feel so [ __ ] real like that then I'll
be interested in doing it do we did be
are like we were like in some like
arcade where we got to do VR in like a
cage you were shooting and [ __ ] and it
felt dope like it was me Joe Barton
Casey and we were all like it was like
we're in a world and when you look up
you just see the sky of the world and
[ __ ] it was crazy dude
yeah we're like at war again so watch
your [ __ ] alien where was this in
Orlando Florida because I hope that's
what we get before I die cuz that that
there's no age restriction on that right
so let's say I'm 80 years old and that
exists [ __ ] dope cap 80 years old
I'll just go to Hawaii or something you
know what I really want to do black man
sooo I want to let people rent my brain
and they can control me I don't know
about that you know what
finally a patreon thing that I'm like oh
yeah I think I'd actually go for that
controlled me for [ __ ] five minutes
alright [ __ ] that that's pretty good
yeah I say what they commit crimes or
they'll be go suck a dick gotta be legal
anymore like my brain went somewhere
else baking inside your thing what is it
I said what if they start sucking a dick
like right before your due to come back
and you come back and you have a dick in
your mouth you got a point there I'd be
pretty traumatized just waking up and
I'm like [ __ ] and you like it what is
this noise
Mitch of the star restaurant it's like
one of those things that you think you
tasted cuz you smelled it before you
know the simulation theory how we're all
like a simulation and there's other
things in spirits controlling us or
whatever what if that's happening that's
what I think about ever since i watch
when we're in a [ __ ] video game
right now yeah bro what I say life is a
game okay like player 1 Joe shoot me
with a gun shoot me shoot me right now
you have all the weapons it's a game
girl I'm not a quick truck but we could
be a game controlling a game like Sims
yeah well what if we already are a sim
and then we are actually controlling
ourselves in this sim pretty good I'm
trying to be on like Elon Musk level it
makes like fun though when you start
looking at life as a game cuz then you
can control everything and try to fix it
we should get high and talk about this
[ __ ] oh we should do a whole day where
we're hi talking about I'm not good
being high I love to get high I want to
do a drunk drunk JD news I'm a news we
do a lot of jokes
it's called sin foods drunk out every
episode that's true you know what's
interesting like I know a couple of
people who are in the weed business that
keep asking me like yo I want to do
podcast stuff like how would I get that
set up or just do videos so what were
high as [ __ ] my mind I'm thinking like
you two are the two dumbest [ __ ] I've
ever been in your shits nothing even be
entertaining at all it's gonna be one
hour of yeah so check it out so they did
it and they sent me that they send it to
me right they took it down nettles on
YouTube it was literally the trashiest
thing I've ever seen in my life it was
an hour of nothing it wasn't even funny
edit it huh did they edit it had like a
little clips take you now can I ask if
they even talked or if they just ran
their hands across it was literally them
doing this yo that's pretty good so far
this is good David you got to be more of
a masochist about this [ __ ] I could sit
there and watch the most painful [ __ ]
Frank Joe could - oh yeah easily yeah
you don't know there's a demographic for
that Joe's the only guy who didn't tap
out I didn't give the opinion it was bad
or not that you sent it to me so I look
but they took it down so it's not up
there anything I made all these fools
watch strap in the closet with me for
Mark Kelly and Josie all no one who
didn't tap out well I already watched it
before exactly
ten exactly it's because I think people
watch things for face value they don't
get fascinated by now the thought
process is when it goes into these
creations what's that other guy that
action dude that Neal Breen he's [ __ ]
funny
he's great you gotta check out Neal B
BRE and double down that is his pH D
resistance that's his masterpiece the
best person that you put me who love the
guy that kept thought investing his
cryptocurrency and he kept loose dude my
dude BZ he changed his whole channel
after I shouted it out oh well I think
people started to find him and he was
getting I think embarrassing comments
that he didn't like which is too bad cuz
I was celebrating him but then now he's
just like a GrubHub driver I guess but
it's funny because he's a driver because
he invested all of his money after
currencies that were I still enjoy it
but it's I wish he kept the old videos
he deleted the other videos
no his career but the best part is when
he was doing grub him he was making good
money he's good and then he got ripped
off at a pump he was putting his card
into one of those pumps in somebody
velcro to fake one on yeah got ripped
off there too oh my god dude is amazing
my dude bzu got it put your videos back
up man yeah when life just kicks you
over and over he is probably supporting
about 10 African Prince's right now and
I was shown this to Nicky and I remember
I was crying and she's like oh this is
kind of sad and I was like well let me
give you the backstory and basically
everyone was telling them that these
were all scams like the whole time you
know the comments like you'll do this is
a scam it's a [ __ ] pyramid scheme
they're gonna [ __ ] pull out they're
gonna you're gonna get dumped on their
your bags will fall on your head and
he's like he's just like you all hate
her
and then he made his viral video which
was uh I lost $35,000 on a bit connect
scam Wow and that was his like breakout
video or whatever it was just like how
adamant he was that people were [ __ ]
biggest ego on earth like these people
are scam after scam he did like five
scams in a row Steve also likes this guy
that it dresses up in a suit and eats
pizza review bro I love him he I've
showed you him yeah he looks like a
clockmaker anybody like reviews pizza
and different fast foods and [ __ ] it is
car yeah in his car people my favourite
like the cringe [ __ ] I'd like to live
for it so I look that's what I look for
on YouTube type like well how like I'm
so curious okay so one of the key things
that I do is I just search for something
that's popular right now because that's
when people usually post right but then
I go to the view count and I look for
like just posted was opposed to like
just now you could find like the usually
the cringes people are just posting they
just released it and they're constantly
pumping the best type of content on
YouTube is are people who create stuff
that they don't think it's funny but
it's actually hilarious yes yes and they
don't understand why their follower
count is going up so high cuz they think
it's because they're good at something
but actually because they're bad like
Chocolate Rain
Chocolate Rain is good though I like
chocolate ran that we used to follow
that saying Bret hit man breaker no hit
I hit my breaker the other guy Oh Nova
Roku Roku Roku
he's our fan too love that guy dude
which one is he he got his [ __ ] hacked
and in a lot of his videos got deleted
but he used to do music videos all the
time he was kind of like William hungee
Oh literally he seems like he has not a
soul in his body ever he always does
like the most hypest songs but with like
a blank face and he's like doing dances
and then he got like a sidekick and it
was like nacho libre in his homie like
it was such a funny combo and I think
what I'm attracted to is like adults
that are innocent yeah
and they don't know that they're doing
something oh my god are you falling
today
yeah my cage white like he's such a pure
soul and in like he's super popular but
it's so [ __ ] hilarious
I like people going from the highest of
highs of the lowest of lows that's my
favorite formula in the video where it's
like somebody who's talking a mad amount
of [ __ ] about something and then they
lose yes all right yes yeah which is why
the ghost ride the whip videos was one
of my favorite trends ever one everyone
liked sets up their car so it
automatically drives and they get other
car and they're all dancing around the
car and then some people got run over by
their own car yeah it's just such a
brazen act of like ballsy nests of like
I [ __ ] rule I'm dancing around my car
nobody's even driving I ruined that oh
[ __ ] I got run over by my car like
that's why just that's my the best
version of that like when people who
pull pranks and they almost get killed
oh so awesome it's good but I just wish
for the rest of us that's true you
didn't there's a couple that died
because of a prank like yeah but they
were like little kids don't talk about
adults who know what they're doing you
know I mean like the guys that come up
and they go to like some random black
people and they try to you know like
that like racist type in the hood shed
yeah like I hope those racist [ __ ] like
just picked I just shot once they could
live do that they were doing that like
in New York yeah but it's like all these
videos where the predator becomes the
prey like store clerk like turns around
and robber I love those videos but I
think my hands-down favorite it is like
a delusional narcissist yes I mean you
you freaking make fun of Instagram
models and I think that kind of falls
under that category where it's like
[ __ ] big ol ass sexualized as hell
and they're talking about hurricane
Harvey or some [ __ ] they don't want to
see me win that should you have [ __ ]
amazing I [ __ ] love that shirt they
don't want you to win I've had people in
grocery stores be like man [ __ ] truth
I love it and then I just go with them
I'm like a man
tell me about it bro it sound like that
it's so fun I just live for that [ __ ] oh
yeah screw strangers but I had a sample
ad gross short one time going just
pointing at me just I love that shirt
for him cuz it's DJ Khaled's thing yeah
they call it on snapchat oh you never
did less up less up they don't want you
to win what do we got cooking today chef
and like cute average chef like prepare
things and it'd be like we have egg
whites toast whole-wheat toast and apple
Ciroc sponsored by apple Ciroc they
don't want you to win the chef would be
like and of course I poster are like it
but not well yeah yeah that's great
[Music]